[Music]
Herot builders recently spoke at a
massive rally for english activist tommy
robinson 20,000 people came out to call
for Tommy's release and builders took
the opportunity to put the political
elites of Britain and continental Europe
on notice
[Applause]
integration
we are almost 4 nerds
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
we can't anymore
it was extraordinary that the British
authorities allowed builders into the
country at all several years ago he was
actually barred from entering Britain
but although the ban was reversed on
appeal the British government recently
banned Martin Selmer Brittany Pettibone
Lauren's southern and Lutz Bachman from
entering all for the crime of opposing
jihad terror and Sharia oppression and
thereby made it clear that the British
government is more authoritarian and
unwilling to uphold the freedom of
speech than ever at least when it comes
to criticism of Islam criticism of
Muslim rape gangs and criticism of mass
Muslim migration even worse the bannings
of Sellner Pettibone southern and
bachmann were just part of a long
pattern panel Aguilar and I were barred
from entering Britain in 2013 apparently
for life also for the crime of telling
the truth about Islam in Jihad meanwhile
Britain has a steadily lengthening
record of admitting jihad preachers
without a moment of hesitation Syed Musa
Farah shocked cadres preaching of hatred
and jihad violence was so hardline that
he was banned from preaching in Pakistan
but the UK home office welcomed him into
Britain the UK Home Office also admitted
sheikh hamza Saudagar into the country
despite the fact that he has said if
there's homosexual men the punishment is
one of five things one the easiest one
maybe chop their head off that's the
easiest second burn them to death third
throw him off a cliff fourth tear down a
wall on them so they die under that
fifth a combination of the above Theresa
Mayes relentlessly appeasement minded
government also admitted to jihad
preachers who had praised the murderer
of a foe of Pakistan's blasphemy laws
one of them was welcomed by the
Archbishop of Canterbury meanwhile the
UK band three bishops from areas of Iraq
and Syria where Christians are
persecuted and they kept them out of the
UK but now matters are coming to a head
apparently British authorities decided
that it would be too politically costly
for them to borrow builders again and so
he entered and he spoke and he gave them
a strong dose of the reality that they
are determined
to ignore and deny Tommy Robinson is in
prison today because he violated a court
order demanding that he not film videos
outside the trials of Muslim rape gangs
clearly the government's intent was to
make sure that as few people as possible
discovered the truth about its massive
years-long cover-up of those rape gangs
and refusal to prosecute the
perpetrators Teresa May and company
obviously hope that other Britons who
are furious about the sacrifice of
thousands of British girls to the idols
of diversity and multiculturalism will
see what happens to Tommy and be
frightened into silence the British
government in imprisoning Tommy Robinson
has shown itself willing to incarcerate
people for having opinions that it
considers unacceptable this heralds the
death of Britain as a free society and
the beginning of an authoritarian police
state there unless this slide to
totalitarianism has stopped now British
public figures whatever criticism they
have leveled against Tommy Robinson in
the past should be calling for him to be
freed today or else they will be
exposing themselves as supporting the
degeneration of Britain into that police
state builders addressed this endeavour
head-on declaring well not science
[Applause]
problems we are lost afraid of you
besides all civilization
- the government's in jail but we will
never be famous
[Applause]
for every coming whom you imprison
thousands will wiser
[Applause]
Louisa may ignore this much Prime
Minister little they know this mrs.
Mirko of president back home
notice the futures is ours my friends we
are builders words don't prove true it
will be because the death of free
societies in Britain and Western Europe
is truly at hand
I'm Robert Spencer the showman fellow
for the David Horowitz freedom Center
and director of jihad watch this video
has been brought to you by the Center
for security policy
[Music]